today's question comes from Heidi in
Missouri she visits Dave Ramsey calm to
ask my husband recently served me with
divorce papers cuz he says I'm not fun
we have a two-year-old daughter I'm
gonna let that sit for a second yeah
while I get pissed off my Bloods boiling
man I believe he's going through a
midlife crisis Beth he's at work that's
what I think he's an idiot he wants to
keep the house and all other assets
leaving me with a car and a small sum of
money
I have $45,000 in student loans and make
fifty eight thousand dollars is it's
smarter to rent or buy I'm gonna answer
the question and I'm gonna try to answer
the question directly before I just get
frustrated and angry too light man guys
you don't get to do this is what I'm
gonna say you don't get to look at your
wife and say hey you know what you're
not fun man you would you don't get to
look at your daughter and say you know
what
mom's not fun I'm out what up not a
choice man unbelievable
so Heidi here's the thing
the last thing you need to be worried
about right now is just rent as cheap as
you can and spend all the rest of your
money on the attorney to get everything
this rat has he doesn't get to this
doesn't get to keep the house and all
the other assets you take all of those
everything you take everything you take
everything this guy ever dreamed of
owning and he deserves nothing and you
take this story to an attorney and
they're gonna smile at you and say come
in sweet Heidi let's have a great great
new file to teach this boy about the law
oh my gosh oh my gosh
gentlemen no that's not gentlemen
there's no gentlemen involved in this
discussion well played
men boys Bajoran males when you hold a
woman's hand and you look her in the
eyes and you tell her family and your
family and God and your friends forever
its forever and when you have a child
together a two-year-old daughter that's
forever let me help you with this when
you have a two-year-old daughter fun
doesn't even enter the discussion fun's
gone there is no fun right then sick of
the cowardice of these men stop yeah
stop Heidi get a good lawyer and have a
field day yeah just give this guy
haircut he'll never forget and but rent
Prince the cheapest thing you can get
stabilized and get your life started
over and here's the good news you now
know what and what picking poorly looks
like and so the next time you pick you
won't pick poorly you will have a
different set of decision-making tools
when you start your dating life again
you're young and a decade from now
you'll have a 12 year old you'll have a
new family a new husband and your life
is going to be amazing so I know it's
like a shadow right now and it's all
over it's not over this is just the down
chapter before things get good mm-hmm
and butt in the butt but rent is cheap
as you can and gets stabilized spend
your money on your attorney so that boy
child gets the haircut he has coming to
him unbelievable hmm we do have a
manhood crisis and I think it's because
we've the culture has made it very
unpopular to be man to be a man you know
like supposedly everything male is a
troglodyte dragging their knuckles
around I've never heard the word
troglodyte old and yeah I mean and you
know you wanted wimpy men now you got
them out there in the culture you know
you wanted manhood to disappear and it
starts gone it's starting to and and so
but there are a few of us left and
we're teaching our sons that that you
the culture were wrong and that the
message you gave them that they were not
worthy to be good dads good husband's be
men of valor be knights of the round
table anytime you told our sons that
we've told them otherwise and so there
are a few of us that are waging war
against you culture and we're not going
to let you win and so it pisses us off
when we run into a creepazoid like this
guy and you know the would suffocation
of America hmm
the woosah fication of our culture to
where a little boy child can walk in and
look at his wife and a unit fun I just
want us yeah not good